Someone gives you one piece of criticism about your work and suddenly you're not just thinking about that one thing you got wrong, you're thinking maybe I'm just not very good at this. Why does feedback about something we've done quickly spiral into a judgment about who we are? And how do we stop one difficult conversation making us question our entire work competence? I'm Dr Marianne Trent and this is in a work. In my most recent long form video, we were talking about fitness to practice at work. And I spoke about an incident where I had been a trainee, where I got some feedback about my work. And it was really, really challenging. So if you are going through this at the moment, I'm sending you my solidarity.
有人对你的工作提出了一点批评，突然之间，你不仅在想那件做错的小事，还在想：也许我根本就不擅长这个。为什么关于我们所做之事的反馈会迅速演变成对我们自身人格的评判？我们该如何阻止一次艰难的对话让我们质疑自己的整个工作能力？我是玛丽安·特伦特博士，这是《内在工作》。在我最近的长视频中，我们讨论了工作中的执业能力。我谈到了我还是实习生时经历的一件事，当时我收到了一些关于工作的反馈。那真的非常、非常具有挑战性。所以，如果你现在正经历这些，我向你表达我的支持。
You might well find that it kind of erode your confidence in so many different areas of life. maybe it really kind of makes you feel like you show up differently in so many of your relationships. And I would say that that can be pretty normal, especially if you know that you find criticism or rejection difficult. There's something called rejection sensitivity dysphoria, which is common in people with ADHD, which can make that feedback feel extra, extra challenging, can make you just want to run away, quit, bury your head. What we need to do is we need to try and stay kind of present in the moment. We need to try and stop our brains from spiraling off into the distance and catastrophizing. So we need to sometimes just have a moment. Take a breath. Drop those shoulders. In through the nose,
你可能会发现这在很大程度上侵蚀了你在生活许多不同方面的自信。也许它真的让你觉得自己在许多人际关系中的表现都变得不同了。我想说，这其实很正常，尤其是如果你知道自己难以接受批评或拒绝的话。有一种东西叫做“拒绝敏感性焦虑”（RSD），这在多动症（ADHD）患者中很常见，它会让反馈听起来格外、格外具有挑战性，让你只想逃跑、辞职、逃避现实。我们需要做的是，试着让自己保持在当下。我们需要试着阻止大脑陷入远虑和灾难化思维。所以，有时我们只需要片刻的停顿。深呼吸。放松肩膀。用鼻子吸气，
out through the mouth, in through the nose, out through the mouth. Try and make sure you're breathing right to the bottom of your lungs, in through the nose, out through the mouth. Now we want to be tuning in to what thoughts you're having and just separating them a little bit because at the moment they are likely presenting themselves to you as facts. And I would anticipate that they are not yet facts. They are kind of swirling, whirling, troubling, troubling thoughts that are running away with themselves. So when we have a thought like, oh, I'm going to fail or I'm going to be sacked or I'm going to lose my house or I'm not going to be able to afford my rent and everyone's going to think that I'm awful and I'm going to feel humiliated and I'm not
用嘴呼气，用鼻子吸气，用嘴呼气。试着确保你的呼吸深入肺底，用鼻子吸气，用嘴呼气。现在，我们要关注你正在产生的想法，并将它们稍微分离开来，因为目前它们很可能以事实的形式呈现在你面前。我预料它们还不是事实。它们只是一种正在失控的、盘旋的、混乱的、令人不安的想法。所以，当我们产生诸如“哦，我要失败了”、“我要被解雇了”、“我要失去房子了”、“我付不起房租了”、“每个人都会觉得我很糟糕”、“我会感到羞辱”以及“我不会”这样的想法时，
going to qualify with the rest of my cohort or, you know, everyone else is going to get to the next pay ban before me. It spirals, it spirals. We just need to take a moment to just add in the phrase, I'm having the thought that, because then it can separate it from that fact. I'm having the thought that other people will be on a bigger payband than me sooner. I'm having the thought that everyone else will say X, Y, Z or think bad things about me. And we just pair that with some breath. And we also talk to someone who actually we think is, generally speaking, kind of on our team, but usually kind of balanced.
“我无法与我的同伴一起获得资格”，或者“其他人都会比我先拿到下一级工资”，这些想法会不断盘旋、不断蔓延。我们只需要花点时间加上“我正在产生……的想法”这句话，因为这样就能把它与事实分离开来。我正在产生“其他人会比我更早拿到更高工资”的想法。我正在产生“其他人都会说某某某，或者对我产生负面看法”的想法。我们只需将其与呼吸结合起来。我们还要与一个我们认为通常站在我们这边，且比较理智的人交谈。
And it might be someone that you often go to for advice. It might be your supervisor. It might be your partner. It might be, you know, a parent. It might be a sibling. It might be, you know, an aunt or an uncle. But someone that genuinely usually helps you find like a safe port in the storm. So it's important that you kind of overcome any shame reaction that you might have for yourself about sharing this with others.
那可能是你经常寻求建议的人。可能是你的主管。可能是你的伴侣。可能是你的父母。可能是你的兄弟姐妹。可能是你的阿姨或叔叔。总之，是一个通常能帮你找到风暴中避风港的人。所以，克服你因与他人分享此事而产生的任何羞耻感是很重要的。
Because actually what I know from my own personal experience of this, but also my own clinical experience of supporting others through really challenging times, is that when we take control from shame and kind of control that narrative, it really can help make things feel much more manageable. With that in mind, if you have had some criticism about your work that might need further investigation or that you might even feel is unjust, it can be helpful to reach out to your union if there is a union in your area of work. And even if you're not currently a member of your union, you might want to consider joining a union. and then I think often they have criteria that they won't help with any direct case that you've got until after three months of you being a member. But you might be like, this might go slightly longer than that.
因为根据我个人的经验，以及我在支持他人度过艰难时期时的临床经验，我知道，当我们从羞耻感中夺回控制权并掌控叙事时，这确实能让事情变得更容易处理。考虑到这一点，如果你收到的工作批评可能需要进一步调查，或者你甚至觉得是不公正的，那么联系你所在工作领域的工会可能会有所帮助。即使你目前不是工会会员，你也可以考虑加入工会。我想他们通常有规定，在你入会三个月之前，他们不会协助处理你现有的直接案件。但你可能会觉得，这件事可能会持续超过三个月。
And so it might be something that you want to kind of take on to kind of see how it rumbles through, but it might be there for you in future. I have been in a union when I worked for local government. I don't think I was in a union at any point since, but it might well be something that you find helpful. And sometimes people even forget that they are part of a union, they just see it come out of their pay slip and they kind of don't think any more about it. So just check whether you might already be a member. It might be that there's also well-being support available and that you might find it helpful to reach out to your HR department too. I do of course understand how reaching out to people at work can feel like.
所以这可能是一件你想继续观察发展的事情，但它在未来可能会对你有帮助。我在地方政府工作时曾加入过工会。我想从那以后我再没加入过工会，但这可能确实是你觉得有帮助的事情。有时人们甚至忘记了自己是工会成员，他们只是看到工资单上扣了钱，就不再多想了。所以，检查一下你是否已经是会员。可能还有可用的心理健康支持，你也可以考虑联系你的人力资源部门。我当然理解联系工作中的人可能会让你觉得，
it makes things worse and it kind of makes things more official but of course we do again need to just check in with the thoughts and the facts distinction again so you might have had feedback from one person and you might have that swirling brain that's kind of assuming that everybody else thinks that about you and actually much earlier in my career I received some feedback and kept it to myself and I shouldn't have done because it was just one erroneous person's feedback and opinion and it wasn't when I later shared that with someone it wasn't the opinion held by other people that were close to me and in my team so yeah it's difficult because I know when there's power
这会让事情变得更糟，让事情变得更正式，但我们当然需要再次区分想法和事实。你可能收到了一个人的反馈，你的大脑可能会胡思乱想，假设其他人也那样看你。实际上，在我职业生涯的早期，我收到过一些反馈，并把它藏在心里，我不应该这样做，因为那只是一个错误的人的反馈和意见。当我后来与人分享时，那并不是我身边团队中其他人持有的观点。所以，是的，这很困难，因为我知道当存在权力
imbalances you know you feel like you know I'm just this person and they are that person but it might just be that individual difference between you and it might it might it might not be fact, okay, but we we do often kind of deal in black and white, fact or fiction, yes and no. So just trying to create a little bit of distance between you and what you're feeling can be really, really important. I think it can also be helpful when it comes to criticism or feedback to kind of be measurable and specific, kind of having a look at maybe what we call our smart goals so specific measurable achievable realistic and time frame and and to think well what actually could I change that would make this difference sometimes we
不平衡时，你会觉得“我只是这个人，而他们是那个人”，但这可能只是你与那个人之间的个体差异，它可能、可能、可能不是事实。好吧，但我们确实经常用非黑即白、事实或虚构、是或否来处理问题。所以，试着在你和你的感受之间创造一点距离是非常、非常重要的。我认为在面对批评或反馈时，做到可衡量和具体也是有帮助的，比如看看我们所谓的“SMART目标”，即具体的、可衡量的、可实现的、现实的和有时限的，并思考：我实际上可以改变什么来产生这种差异？有时我们
can be so kind of upset about the feedback that we maybe can't tune into some of that as maybe there's some element of that that is true maybe we could you know benefit from a little bit more structure maybe we could benefit from a little bit more discussion before we kind of leap headlong into things. Maybe we could benefit from just slowing down, taking a breath, letting things unfold. But sometimes it can make us feel that we can't do any of that and that all of that person's feedback and criticism is wrong. There might be elements of that that actually you can digest and that do sit better with you over time, even if not immediately. I think again it's important to think about not making this and I'll show them.
可能会因为反馈而感到非常沮丧，以至于我们可能无法意识到其中可能有一些真实的部分。也许我们可以从更多的结构中受益，也许在仓促行事之前，我们可以从更多的讨论中受益。也许我们可以从放慢脚步、深呼吸、让事情自然发展中受益。但有时这会让我们觉得我们什么都做不了，那个人的所有反馈和批评都是错的。其中可能有一些部分实际上是可以消化的，并且随着时间的推移，即使不是立即，也会让你感觉更好。我认为再次强调不要把它变成“我会让他们看看”的想法是很重要的。
you know, I'll prove them vendetta. I guess just try and keep this as contained as you can, but be honest with the people that care about you, the people around you, and know that this will pass. We can be so tied up in our work, kind of professional identity as also being ourselves, our personal identity.
你知道，“我会证明给他们看”，这是一种报复心理。我想，尽量把这件事控制在一定范围内，但要对关心你的人、你身边的人诚实，并知道这一切都会过去。我们太容易把工作、职业身份与我们自己、我们的个人身份捆绑在一起了。
I know I'm the position as a clinical psychologist, but yeah, kind of leaning into some of the things that are outside of your professional identity, such as exercise, such as time with your friends, can be really, really important in helping you weather the storm. I would love your thoughts about this. What are you going through right now? Please do drop me a comment.
我知道我是一名临床心理学家，但是的，倾向于做一些职业身份之外的事情，比如锻炼、与朋友共度时光，对于帮助你度过风暴真的非常、非常重要。我很想听听你对此的想法。你现在正在经历什么？请给我留言。
Please also do let me know whether you're enjoying these deeper dive inner work episodes. I would love to know. If you have enjoyed this one, I think you'll also enjoy this one. the Inner Work episode on self-optimisation versus self-acceptance and kind of getting that balance right. So do check that one out. The next episode of Inner Work will be available. Wherever you get your podcasts and on YouTube at 8pm UK time on Wednesday. Thanks for being part of my world. I'll see you soon. Take care. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
也请让我知道你是否喜欢这些更深入的《内在工作》剧集。我很想知道。如果你喜欢这一集，我想你也会喜欢这一集：《内在工作》关于自我优化与自我接纳，以及如何平衡这两者。所以一定要去看看。下一集《内在工作》将于英国时间周三晚上8点在各大播客平台和YouTube上发布。感谢你成为我世界的一部分。我们很快再见。保重。这一集还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。